if you're running a business and you're
frustrated with how long it's taking you
to get things going to make the money
you think your deserve to make remember
that it takes time if you look at any
successful business it's not an
overnight success these things take time
and so don't get too frustrated or down
on yourself if you're not getting
instant results hi I'm Evan Carmichael
your friend and all things
entrepreneurship and I want to convey
that message to business owners because
we get frustrated we get angry and I've
been there you know you feel like you
should be further ahead and you're
frustrated with how long it's taking you
to get going and you're working hard and
you put everything you have into it
you're not slacking off it still is
going to take time you have to have the
patience you got to stick around and
wait for your opportunities to come you
have to allow momentum to build one of
my favorite famous entrepreneur stories
is Harley Davidson started by two
friends one named Harley wedding
Davidson and when they started they
wanted to build motorcycles they went to
their backyard built an eight-by-ten
shed made a homemade sinus at
harley-davidson and hung it on the front
and they got to work they didn't have
venture capital they didn't have angel
investors they didn't let that hold them
back from getting started and put
everything he had into their business
they started with one motorcycle then
they built three then they built a dozen
they invested their profits back into
the business and it grew and it took
time to do it then they had enough money
to build a factory so they went out and
did that and they built 50 and they kept
building more and more and more and more
motorcycles and today the company's
worth over 5 billion dollars but it
takes time at the beginning it's not
easy and too many entrepreneurs quit too
soon you quit just as the momentum is
building up and I know it's frustrating
to put all that hard work and energy in
every day and not see any return you
just see darkness around you but you've
got to trust that if you love what
you're doing and
you're helping people that those dots
will connect in the future it will make
sense you will make a lot of money you
just have to keep going remind yourself
that it takes time and read any famous
entrepreneur story how they got started
and you'll see the hard work blood sweat
tears that went into it you got to do
the same it's not going to be handed to
in a silver platter you gotta work the
cover is not coming this is on you to do
I want you to get frustrated and I want
you get angry that is taking a long time
I want you to plow that back into your
business don't let it discourage you and
keep you from moving forward and don't
let it make you give up your company
give up your dream remember that it
takes time how'd the focus I have the
patience to keep going thank you for
joining me for this episode if you guys
liked it please give it a thumbs up
makes want to do more for you and I'd
love to hear what you have to think if
you leave a comment under the video or
we have a question for your business
I'll see you in the next episode
you